would you eat human meat because well
this is like
um the animal rights movement really
because they don't want you to eat
animal meat the answer is no I won't eat
human what is wrong with you people did
you find the one about lab-grown salami
cultured from celebrities lab groans
I've seen that human oh here we go we've
before it's it's like an animal right
would you eat lab-grown human salami
cultured from celebrity cells no why so
long James Franco's salami they're
hoping to get James Franco and Ellen
DeGeneres Jennifer Lawrence and Kanye
West on board donate tissue samples that
will become Solano I don't think Kanye
would be down knowing I don't think he'd
be down with that you make a lot could
you imagine the amount of money that
someone could make probably so much it's
only legal in Idaho though Idaho's
unless it allows that this is like some
of the most disgusting stuff I've ever
seen yo we need to go back there was
also another joke not too far too far
too far there was also an article I read
um they said would you eat um human meat
to save the planet
here's what I'm saying how about I think
I have this video somewhere here we go
check out this video
this is uh I saw this history defined
High School fitness program in 1962.
technical education director at La
Sierra High School has developed a
program that assures every student of
physical look at this
this is normal back then for all of the
kids somebody filmed last year you can't
even play dodgeball anymore so
extensional boys school or they separate
by gender I'm pretty sure they all did
so I'm kind of saying here's what I'm
saying can we like go back to when we
you know exercise and ate right but you
know keep the getting rid of racism part
and then just have like the not racism
but still be exercising and eating right
and not having human grown this is toxic
masculinity now this is just a bunch of
teenagers exercising as they should be
but nowadays it's just like the kids sit
around doing nothing well if you make
them exercise and they can't do it then
you make them feel bad and that's bad
because that's bullying man it's like
it's like social Darwinism or whatever
strong must survive let the let the
people who want to be doughy be doing
most people want to be fit be fit do you
want to cater to like the lowest
denominator or should we all like try to
encourage everyone to reach their
Highest Potential right that's why we're
gonna lower the standards that's good
that's part of like the assisted suicide
conversation like I'm very much just
cater to the best of the best and let
everyone else fall away if they can't
keep up then they're not supposed to
evolutionarily see with this June class
example I feel like it's way worse to be
like you couldn't do a push-up so you
just don't have to do them like we know
you're not capable that's a terrible
thing to communicate to a teenager right
being like hey you can't do push-up but
by the end of the semester maybe you'll
be able to do five and that's awesome
that's an improvement like that's way
better shaving or something exactly
yeah I guess there's if we are going
into the Techno verse that your emotions
are going to be a key part in your
ability to navigate so angry people
could make bad things and you want to
like make sure people are happy and
healthy but the problem is man giving
someone everything they want when
they're little is not what makes people
happy you need people need adverse
adversity they need competition of
course they need to lose and they need
to learn how to enjoy it
that's how you do the future is going to
be humans are going to be short and
gangly and gaunt super thin wearing
jumpsuits and they're going to live in
pods but in the pods they're going to be
six feet tall super ripped flying around
you know with with spaceships and all
that stuff yeah
ever so I think the future is androgyny
because we see all of this gender
transitioning happening and I think that
the ideal will eventually be you know an
androgynous model yeah I was thinking
that we're going to be just raising
gestating in like pods the kids and then
adults won't have sex organs will be
super tall because we'll be in Low
Gravity have really long arms and legs
have you guys watched sg1
this is basically what happens to one of
the aliens like the the alien there what
are they the the nordics what do they
call them I forgot what they call them
in the show uh but they're like Grays
and they can't reproduce anymore they
can only clone themselves and they're
they're they're degrading so they can't
do it much longer and they eventually
just get wiped out because of it what
were you about to oh I was just to say
in the early 2000s I remember reading
some fashion magazine to a cover on like
the Top Model yeah sorry guys the
highest like most in demand and it was a
man who was known for his androgynous
look and he's very thin and like Tim
saying like long arms stuff like that
yeah the fashion industry to this day is
doing the same well and this was like I
think I read this article in 2010 right
so at that time they already were like
this is the ideal for both men and women
because they were saying this like he's
able to walk runway for men's lines but
also for women's lines right but he's
not shaped like we would think a
traditional toxically masculine male
ideally is and he's not
and how do we get to that ideal of
androgyny by flipping so and making
the body unhealthy right right so the
fashion industry they're making men wear
dresses and then they're making women
you know wear more masculine clothing so
that is the first step to reaching that
ideal of androgyny so I think that
definitely and they're 10 years ahead
like if we're just talking about it now
they've already known it for a while I
was thinking like how uh all wars are
fought for sex I don't know some people
have told me that over time like all all
wars are fought over women or some some
like that so that's to Helena Troy
that's like the one thing I'm pretty
sure a lot of us wars in the world were
fought over uh black peppercorn oh
wasn't it salt well I guess so all
seasons all that stuff food for sure but
the aggression over over women over
either guys not getting laid so he goes
he gets angry or a guy wants the woman
so he goes like maybe the sexuality is
what has caused us to be so psychotic as
a species is our obsession with finding
a mate and taking other people's mates
and I disagree as an explain the East
India Trading Company uh trade uh trade
company and the the spot
it was literally
pepper black pepper they were like I
will kill thousands to make my eggs
taste better it was it's also the profit
off the black pepper the amount of money
they could make so much what about
female leaders that go to war like
Boudicca I mean Margaret Thatcher for
example not true yeah not all war is for
sex obviously that's ridiculous but it's
for pepper a lot of male aggression is
because of it I think in nature male
aggression is often because of female
stuff what you think about like the I
remember what they are but the Rams that
get interlocked because they're trying
to beat each other to like how do you
define male aggression just displays of
aggression right so if you're talking
about these Rams they just bite each
other being a man I mean I think
aggression is a naturally masculine
that's what I'm saying but like the uh
there are times when it becomes fatal
right if your land Rams who lock
together and die because you're trying
to seduce it or show the girl that like
you were the better stronger the two
like it can be at times not the best you
need a certain amount of aggression you
don't need to doubt it but like I think
you're right we link a in nature sex and
aggression are often linked but I don't
think it's necessarily the only cause of
War I wonder if it's being bred out of
humanity if people are attempting to
lower the aggression and the sexuality
to an androgynous State it's crossed my
mind like five ten years ago and I
wonder if it's a technocratic state of
mind thing like we need these people not
testosterone filled because they're too
much too much fist fights too much lying
so that's physical aggression but then
on the female side there's emotional
aggression right because I mean they're
influenced by estrogen and everything so
yeah and aggression yeah I feel like
it's worse I would do but I think it's
well they have that thing where they say
like men like women like men if there's
a problem like eventually can just hit
each other right yeah but with women
like and then you'll get over it yeah
yeah but they're hitting each other
never never solves it I don't think and
I don't think so but they assert
dominance and that's sort of the natural
order of like the difference between men
and women it does solve it though right
the beef is over it solves it in the
physical sense like the guy's not gonna
do you think that the dudes are like
emotionally upset with each other after
they win a fight or something probably I
mean if you're not working it out
emotionally or or consciously like I
don't think it's getting worked out what
kind of fight are you do you mean like a
guy and two guys want a woman they get
into a fist fight the guy breaks the
other guy's legs breaks his neck and now
he's like he didn't just okay
we're at tribal now so we have no choice
because otherwise we'll come back later
um yeah and it's kind of crazy if you
think about I was in Norway and the
Norwegian is Norwegian guy and it's
funny because they're all kind of woke
he was like you want to hear a joke and
I was like and he's like how come
Britain has no beautiful women and I was
like why
and then uh I was like oh it was right
because the Vikings went and raided and
took all the women and I'm like I don't
know if that's a joke or like it's not
but the crazy thing is like I'm imagine
like you're a woman in a village in like
the British house or whatever in Great
Britain or something or Wales or
Scotland and then all of a sudden a
bunch of Burly dudes on a boat just walk
up destroy your village and take you and
bring you back to their Village and it's
like this is your life now yeah true
like that's just it like okay I guess
yeah God I you know the horrible I talk
about this horrible horrible stuff but
it's only because I want people to think
about what it could be you can't just
call call the cops like if we really
screw this up you know this American
thing
watch watch 18 I'm watching 1883 because
you know you guys were telling me to
watch it yeah yeah it's just like
everybody dying all the time it's a bit
ridiculous it's just like they're
walking and all of a sudden like there's
like there's a scene where they're
talking about this and a girl goes to
take a leak or something and a snake
bites her ass and then she's dead like
her corpse is lying on the ground like
what else make better ass look I think
that what was that video game was
popular organ Trail like I don't think
it prepared us for what the West was
really like that's why I liked watching
YouTube
the way they did like this where the
Marshall walks into the Romans like who
did it bang bang bang just kills
everybody say the depictions of law
enforcement and how that works but like
the risk to The Travelers like while
they're going like the snakes in the
wagon and the whatever else like that is
real right it seems kind of crazy today
because
there are there are very like
rudimentary things we've learned like in
grade school that can really make a
difference that they didn't know and if
you think about it like just it's to put
it simply there were people at a time
who didn't know what a wheel was
and we all know what a wheel is because
we've just seen it we've never had a
workshop class on how to make a wheel we
probably struggle to figure out how to
make a perfect wheel out of wood or
something but eventually we'd figure out
something how to make something roll but
there was a period where people didn't
have wheels nobody figured it out nobody
knew nobody saw it now it's like if we
really needed to you could probably make
a wheel with something you just do it
because you know the concept of it so
when it comes to like the Oregon Trail
there's a bunch of stuff you may have
just seen passively watching the
Discovery Channel and you're like oh
yeah you know like how to get water at
night it's like you dig a little hole
and you put like a leaf in it or
something and you get like a cup or
whatever connotation forms and it drips
into the cup there's just like stuff
that you learn from watching movies that
these people never had access to think
about this well germ Theory right sorry
oh right yeah like washing wounds they
used to be like why wash your hands yeah
or like you have to boil your water
before you drink it right they didn't
know that because they didn't have the
concepts but in 1883 they're boiling the
water because of Cholera but they have
to tell them to right but so think about
this
when you watch a movie you get a bunch
of BS information and people think the
wrong things from watching it though
that people think that like silencers
make guns go you you they really don't
and uh they really don't know what these
things sound like but um there's there
is a there is so much information we
absorb every single day that we take for
granted if you go back to 1883 you
probably absorbed no information for for
days like literally the information you
absorb is like an animal was there okay
well that's not like longevity
information right I'm talking like today
you know I'll read an article and it'll
be like a new Fusion reactor it it
combines these things with these things
I'm like I don't know I just learned
something I guess and I don't know I
want to practically apply like a fusion
reactor or something but you go back to
the 1800s and you're walking the whole
day and you learn nothing new the only
thing new you learn is like there's a
tree at this point on the map write it
down you know we've also seen this
transition from you know TV culture to
internet culture right we have all of
the world's knowledge at our fingertips
24 7. you know
30 years ago we wouldn't be able to
Google like some stupid you know piece
of information that we were looking for
but now we can it's crazy that was
actually uh that was a comic I think it
was XKCD I'm not sure where someone it's
like 1990 and someone said hey what year
was Lincoln shot another person's like I
don't know you want to go to the library
and find out nah and then it's like now
hey what year was Lincoln shot then he's
looking at his phone he's like 1864. I
don't know was it 1864 what year was it
that he was shot 1865 was like 24 ended
right yeah right after the war right it
was like a month after the war ended up
yeah 65 65. that makes sense right can't
go anywhere without your history what
year was it April 14th 1865. 65. you
were right right I was close I was close
yeah to this point you know um when I
had that Twitter space with the Taliban
I was telling you uh about before I
co-hosted it with Nuance bro and we were
discussing the detainment of Andrew Tay
and I got Mega people together with
these Taliban guys living in Afghanistan
they actually had a very fruitful
conversation about you know where the
world was headed can you imagine if we
could do this back in 2000 and one maybe
the world was crazy thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time